esto es sant dennis bajo medidas
reforzadas contra el cob y 19 el mercado
está repleto cualquiera puede entrar y
salir sin preocuparse por la distancia
social
para muchos vecinos se deberían aplicar
más restricciones para mantener el virus
bajo control
a esto lo llaman cuarentena
no estoy ni a favor ni en contra pero
necesitamos medidas sanitarias
regulación de la circulación esto es
anarquía
sin embargo la zona es una de las más
golpeadas en francia la tasa de contagio
semanal está casi en 800 casos por cada
100.000 personas más del doble de la
media nacional
ser una de las zonas más pobres de
francia tiene que ver con la rápida
expansión del virus
kobe si los residentes de aquí no tienen
más opción que ir en transporte público
viven en apartamentos pequeños donde
aislarse con un familiar infectado es
difícil
amalia de usan la cem y las escuelas
causan una preocupación particular a
pesar de que trabajar desde casa fue
difícil durante la cuarentena los
alumnos quieren que esta escuela cierre
temporalmente casi 50 estudiantes se
contagiaron sólo en este mes sepa cómo
se trasponga sanz no me preocupa por mí
pero me contagio pondría mi familia en
los cuidados intensivos en sense and
then y están llenos la zona tiene la
tasa de vacunación más baja en la
francia metropolitana menos del 7 por
ciento de la población está vacunada la
mitad de los vacunados en parís